breaking news Anish giri has refuted
chess that's right I'm taking a look
today at a game between Aneesh Gary and
Vladislav
Kovalev where Aneesh came up with some
very interesting ideas in the Italian
and might have given black very very
serious problems that he'll need to
consider so why don't we just jump right
in and take a look at the game of course
the Italian starts with E 4 E 5 9 f3
knight c6 Bishop c4 Bishop c5 and we are
deep in the joke Oh piano c3 is White's
choice preparing to expand in the center
Knight f6 hits this pawn white plays d3
defending well enough d6 and now Anish
plays Bishop g5 and this is the move
that kind of denotes like a side line
usually in the joke okay no white has
castled here historically or played
Bishop b3 or an IBD 2 or even these days
some b4 stuff gaining some space early
on on the Queen's side but Geary chooses
not the most popular move Bishop g5
pinning this Knight to the Queen
historically White has her Black has
responded the way that Vladislav koulev
responded in the game with h6 after
Bishop age 4 white goes ahead and plays
a6 as well now just giving this Bishop
an extra square to tuck itself away on
white plays Knight BD - and now black
retreats this Bishop before white has
time to play d4 or b4 kicking it away
here white simply castles black castles
as well now we see a four and this is
pretty typical these days of high-level
Italian games this a four move is really
gaining in popularity
and the idea is you want to gain some
space on the Queen side
historically the Italian hasn't given
white too much of an edge here but with
this new idea to start gaining some
queenside space it is proving a little
bit more difficult for black to solve
all of his problems and so we'll see
here black played in a very common
manner with g5 you'll also see sometimes
they start with King h7
but g5 is is quite quite common here g5
pushing this bishop back
note that Knight takes d5 is actually a
playable move here but Gary shows a
different line with with Bishop g3 of
course the idea though with 95 is that
you you get a very nice pin on this
night and a lot of pressure with the
white pieces but Bishop g3 is his choice
instead and now black plays this move
King g7 and on the surface this this
position doesn't look too threatening
for white here it doesn't really it's
not super clear what what white intends
to do but after the next few moves Gary
actually had a pretty substantial
advantage and when I was going over this
game trying to prepare it for this
lecture or video or game review or or
news bulletin I was finding it very
difficult to find where blacks mistake
was in this opening to get such a
disadvantage I mean it turns out I think
this move King g7 is actually a little
bit too slow and we'll see why in just a
moment here instead perhaps black should
expand on the Kings side a little bit
more quickly he wants to play this move
h5 to start with though he needs to
defence his pawn on g5 with a move like
Knight age 7 and perhaps after Age 3 and
age 5 this is the advantage in time he
needs not spending a tempo on King g7
you can compare this position to what
happened in the game where so if b4 now
there's an h4 move in a g4 move and
blacks play on the Kings side comes
pretty quickly but we'll compare it with
what happens in the game here where
after King g7 white plays rook e1 and
this move supports the center but more
importantly clears the f1 square for the
knight now we see knight eh
the very similar idea and after h5 and
h3 h4 bishop h 2g for the idea for black
is to expand further on the kingside and
use this bishop now to create an awkward
pin on this knight on f3 but due to this
wasted tempo White's play actually comes
very very quickly so the idea of White's
plan on the Queen side is he wants to
actually play in the center which isn't
the most intuitive but the reason why it
has been avoiding d4 is because this
Black Knight controls the square quite
effectively and it's difficult to get
enough support to push through so first
white is pushing through on the Queen
side with this move b5 and takes as
possible but instead black simply plays
97 and now with the removal of this
Knight d4 is in fact played here and
this is a pretty powerful idea actually
from Gary it's not so easy to meet all
of the problems presented here by this
push in the center you could capture
white will simply capture back and then
if you dare to take on d4 this is where
things get a little bit crazy first
we'll take on a6 if you take my rook
I'll take back with check and then take
b7 so you should recapture here first
and now white simply plays a move Queen
c1 daring you to actually capture this
exchange of course the idea of Quincy
want us to unpin so you should take the
Queen captures back okay now after f6
actually gonna pick up this pawn as well
and this is going to be very very
dangerous for black this is not
something you really want to go into
here the two bishops are actually going
to be quite powerful now as well as this
Queen on the long open diagonal the f5
Square is available for the night and
this King is going to be very very loose
and this would be a ton of compensation
for white here
so this d4 move actually just gets to
stand on the board and this is a huge
problem for black will see black
continues with Knight g6 trying to take
advantage of this f4 square
but now we see B takes a 6b takes a6 and
white simply continues with the
national plan of night f1 now there's no
ideas of capturing this pun because the
Queen simply defense in fact though
black does capture here and after Bishop
takes f3 now we really don't actually
want to give up this pawn so we take
back with the pawn and now black kind of
was led astray a bit he thought he
needed to break down this very very
strong center which is a very natural
thing to think and so he played the the
committal move f5 but in fact this move
is is pretty close to just losing it
weakens far too much and Geary took
advantage of it instead though I was
looking here at first and trying to find
an improvement for black and it turns
out this position is just very very bad
this is not a good position for black at
all this centre is far too strong and
this is why earlier on he needed to play
a little bit more or actively a little
more quickly you see this move King g7
didn't really turn out to be useful the
idea I think is is to bring a rook
behind the King but in facts black never
finds time to do this White's playing
the center comes too quickly so this
ended up just being a wasted tempo and
if you compare what happened in the game
to what would have happened if he didn't
waste this tempo on King g7 well the
difference is he has enough time to deal
with this d4 push and if d4 doesn't come
then blacks position is totally fine and
in fact quite favorable due to the
pressure along this knight on f3 so let
this be a word of warning always be
careful how you spend your Tempe early
on in the opening because it could come
back to haunt you especially if you're
playing a niche Gary so perhaps some
better tries would have been something
like Queen f6 or even King h8 stepping
off of you know a Knight f5 check
instead though black wanted to challenge
the center with f5 but the fact is
there's real note no real threat here
so simply 93 and after F ticks have
takes we see a Queen g5 check King h1
comes on the board and rook takes f2 is
played and now this is a pretty pretty
complicated
as you can probably imagine here the
black major pieces are invading just a
little bit on this second rank here and
the night seemed to be very threatening
Lee placed to come into play
in just a moment here but in fact white
has no problems the best line is
actually for white to play Bishop g1
rook b2 and after rooks or Queens c1
rather this rook has no squares to run
to on the second rank so it must be
defended and now after Bishop b5 there's
simply no way to defend this truck it's
a nice interference tactic here for for
white rook b3 is possible but now this
rook this works problems continue with
Queen c2 or even the Queen takes a c7
but the idea of capturing this bishops
so this would have been totally winning
for white instead though Geary did did
not find the most accurate way to play
stead choosing night of five check which
of course removes the protector of g2 so
after King g8 or King h8 rather white
must play with g1 to avoid getting
checkmated black goes for take sage to
check King takes h2 queen of four check
King age three night g5 check and of
course these Knights are too powerful so
white simply gives the exchange back
with rook takes g5 and Queen takes g5
now aiming to trade off some of these
pieces Giri goes for Queen G one after
another check we do see the trade of
Queens and here this endgame is simply
quite nice for for white the reason for
that bidding this King is very very weak
you can imagine some checkmating threats
actually appearing on the board and this
pawn is definitely going to fall and in
the meantime it's not so easy for black
to find meaningful targets in fact black
tries this move d5 immediately trying
desperately to cut off this bishop from
its attack on the king and after Bishop
takes d5 we see Knight takes d5 and pawn
takes d5 now White has regained the pawn
that he was down
here like really needed to play a move
rook g8 to get this rook off of this
annoying file instead though black tried
rook e8 and now after King age three
there's a Bishop e6 King takes h4 like I
said this pawn was always going to fall
rook d8 is blacks choice aiming for this
pawn however this move rook g5 is very
very annoying and actually technically
defends this pawn I'll let you at home
try to find the tactic if it takes d5
okay okay that's right
you found it I'm so proud of you rook h5
check King g8 in 97 would be picking up
the rook so Rick g5 defends this
defenseless pawn king aged 7 was blacks
try to try and renew the threat however
after her cage 5 check in King g6 and a
knight check and King f6 this Knight now
comes to c6 a very powerful Square rook
e8 rookie v / KH 8 king g4 black tries a
5 and the rest of this game is really
just this night being very very powerful
and the white piece is kind of ganging
up on this black King to prove a winning
advantage 95 check King g7 rook g5 check
this King has to come to age 7 now very
very awkward this work comes to h5 and
then Gary calculated that the minor
piece endgame was was simply winning
after a move Knight c4 you don't want to
capture this pawn because I'll be able
to capture this a pawn then after knight
c6
I guard all the necessary squares this
King is way too out of play to be
relevant so after King g7 Gary just
brings his king closer King f7 and now
the move d6 forced resignation from
Kovalev of course the idea being you
can't take because of the bishop and if
the bishop moves or the King moves we're
simply going to capture and have an
extremely winning King and pawn endgame
this one is pretty simple
with that of minds did gear a few chests
maybe not maybe Kovalev just needed to
be a little bit more careful with his
Tempe in the opening not spending so
much time playing moves like King g7
instead advancing on the Kings side to
meet White's threats on the Queen side
with pace with that of Mines thank you
so much for joining me for another
episode of game review my name is Caleb
Denby and I will see you next time